it could be game over for PC fans
waiting to play the next rock band I'm
Dave and welcome to your heavy metal
news update Harmonix launched a
crowdfunding campaign to bring rock band
4 to pc but it has a significant hurdle
to overcome the rhythm game campaign has
just 24 hours left to reach its goal but
still needs more than 750,000 dollars to
succeed if it doesn't reach its goal it
may never come to PC fig campaign is
looking for 1.5 million dollars and
intends to bring rock band 4 and rock
band network to the PC rock band network
allowed players to put their own songs
into rock band 3 but was closed down in
2014 due to the amount of work that had
to be put in to keep it running however
if rock band 4 does in fact come to
steam develop a harmonic sale be a lot
easier to implement via Steam Workshop
the raised money if successful would be
used to pay sumo digital to port the
game to pc the full cost of development
would be 2 million dollars and harmonics
said it would provide the other 500,000
if it reached its goal about halfway
through the campaign harmonics added a
new rewards here that would give people
the entire DLC song library if they paid
two and a half thousand dollars Harmonix
participated in a reddit AMA in which
the developer said that the PC would not
be dead to it if rock band 4 isn't
funded it's more about whether or not it
makes sense to bring the future games
the platform the developer said rock
band VR is coming to oculus which is
obviously PC and I can definitely see
other titles fitting nicely on PC as
well Harmonix isn't new to crowdfunding
the developer sought funding for another
rhythm game amplitude back in 2014 it
was a successful campaign raising over
800 thousand dollars so has anyone got a
cool three quarter of a million to
donate today do you think rock band 4 is
the right fit for a PC let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and for your
hard rocking news stay tuned to gamespot
com
you